[Music]
it's this week we got cyber virus stand
your ground and beat the heat take it to
[Laughter]
prices right in here so first story
there is this new viral cyber attack
that's happening and it's it's actually
airborne so this is kind of scared it's
a viral airborne attack - but it's cyber
in a cyber I would like to airdrop
airdrop it's actually a Bluetooth
cyberattack that's happening so it's
called blue born so if I take my phone
off on Bluetooth I'm safe yeah okay good
yeah as soon as I read this my Bluetooth
off no so apparently what's happening
they discovered this new virus that
attacks a weakness and the Bluetooth
software and so the way it spreads is
any device that has Bluetooth
capabilities on it'll spread to it
without the user even knowing oh no so
this way it spreads what exactly it
spreads this virus called blue born okay
but we don't know what it does it okay
mother yeah so it they're just
describing it as a malicious new virus
and it bucks your phone up it has like
malware that goes into your device and
it pretty much holds it for ransom like
it can give you a notification kind of
what recently happened with the wanna
cry ransom software did you hear about
that yeah weird like pay bitcoins to get
you get your [ __ ] back yeah and a lot of
Red Coins
they didn't even receive their their
device again like they it was just it
was done and so what's happening here is
that they're saying that this could
potentially affect up to eight billion
devices around the world building I
think it definitely affected my phone
it's a sense so mean [ __ ] to my wife the
other day it happened
it's the virus it said some dick pics
just some chicks on them and they robbed
me and that's an invasion of my privacy
[Laughter]
as I can in fact Windows Linux Android
and iOS devices prior to the iOS 10 so
if you have any devices that I should
upgrade yeah it's a conspiracy it's by
Apple they're trying to sell the new
phone that's what it is well they're
saying it affects everyone did we shoot
a new Android the new phone can we talk
they're taking out their stripping it
away of everything it's just a screen
give a [ __ ] about this phone man you can
talk like the poop emoji that was their
big funnel right there like as a feature
it's dinosaur in the background I was
like right and they're trying to sell it
as a feature for the phone what the [ __ ]
I know I guess what else we got guys we
got wireless charging I'm like and
they're like we really think Steve Jobs
will be real proud of us I don't think
so no [ __ ] way he's like you guys did
a phone again he's like how many goddamn
phones are we gonna do guys where's the
Apple car where's the Apple TV that's
actually a TV that does something cool
that's true you know I'm saying thank
you for waiting for like where's all
that like cool [ __ ] like I would take an
Apple fridge at this point like I'm sick
of all this like another phone it's
smaller this speakers are even smaller
than ever it's like is it the 7 no
numbers it's the aid in the tent yeah
and what what's cool about I just see
people taking I mean showing pictures of
the gold one or the copper one I think
it's the they're trying to do the the
bezel is like no button thing I think it
was just dumb cuz like the feature was
like you could turn your face into an
emoji that's not a [ __ ] feature dude
and oh god God knows man it's like man
now you know what's real [ __ ] about my
phone I have to like push down on it
real quick to open it takes forever to
get in my phone now I can just look at
my phone and my phone knows I want to
stop like how many how many times like
in our lives are we at like say a
Halloween party or something and it's
like oh [ __ ]
pain in the ass I'd rather be able to do
this [ __ ] like give me a break but see
that's I'm saying but when you have your
head up your ass and you're at the Apple
campus and you're walking around like
what if we got rid of the button look
you don't mean like that
right it's through this headphone jack
[ __ ] thing is one of the ice I
thought I would get used to it I still
haven't gotten me I can't believe they
got rid of that [ __ ] stupid so you
had the one without the headphone jack
oh yes and a wire stop [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's why I stick with the second
airport like when your honor you want to
charge your phone and listen to some
[ __ ] in the plane you're [ __ ] you're
right I just gotta just chill for the
next hour
yeah bluetooth headphones but then you
you're you're risking this and then you
up then with your bluetooth headphone
other batteries you're [ __ ] and that
happens so quickly badly it's pretty
useless it comes with that adapter piece
and the adapter when I try to plug my
headphones into it it doesn't even fit
because there's a [ __ ] different
adapter like what's the even point of it
right they're forcing us to go and
coming from Apple then they got rid of
forcing us to use bluetooth the
technology for the cup no this my races
is preventing you from using bluetooth
so how would we know because they're
trying to sell the new phones anything
above iOS 10 right so the new phones so
it affects anything below conspiracy by
our new [ __ ] phones well and they
know that I don't update that [ __ ] cuz
every time I update it I hate it yeah it
always changes something that I done
didn't want change remember when they
added news to it I was like I don't want
your [ __ ] shitty I don't want your
shitty ass news all over my phone good
news is terrible
I know I'm gonna hate that they don't
even let you customize a lot of the [ __ ]
like you want to get rid of certain
things and it doesn't let you know
anything and my music now is like such a
painting I don't even know how to even
click a song now do the [ __ ] iTunes
thing got hella more complicated I hated
that [ __ ] I still don't know how to use
it well my [ __ ] I think Apple was just
Steve Jobs brain yeah and there's a
Winnie left how many more years do the
Apple has before they they're gonna be
dethroned you know what I think everyone
keeps on opening their mouths and saying
ah like for everything Apple does so for
all I know like as a cynical [ __ ]
probably forever
because everyone loves a goddamn new
iPhone that's true cuz people I can't
wait to get it I can't wait to get it so
it's like next year it's I've got no
screen now it's like come out with a
foldable phone that's cool that's
different it's actually different yeah
back to the old school flip phones
Motorola's yeah but an actual like cool
little screen hold it's like all biz
this way yeah like a notebook or
something it's like it's like a Nintendo
I mean it's something else different
yeah different yeah but they're saying
back to this blue boy virus thing
they're saying that I could even affect
hospital equipment that has Bluetooth
capabilities son it's kind of scary but
we just need to go back to the old days
what can you do other than just update
whatever you need to update
I mean updating [ __ ] my family been here
all these years a weird updated we're
gonna update alright for our next story
so did you guys hear about this Facebook
event for hurricane
Irma to actually shoot at the hurricane
so it can turn back yeah I heard people
were shooting at it shooting yeah I'm
sorry doing one shooting the guns
yeah can I just say I think this is
awesome so we have this Facebook event
it says shoot at hurricane EMA and then
the detail would you like to read yeah
absolutely
yo so this is goofy yo so this goofy
look in windy heady head ass named Irma
said they pullin up on us let's show her
ma that we shoot first what man we stand
our ground I think that's great so this
went viral 56,000 people that were
interested in this event and some oh my
god so it spread really quickly to the
point where cops actually had to tweet
out they had to tweet out of course to
clarify do not shoot weapons at you
won't make it turn around and it will
have very dangerous side effects cousin
they also hosted this but there were
people really shooting at the hurricane
though so that's the thing I couldn't
find reports of people that were
actually shooting it because the people
that created this event they were saying
that I was
a joke like obviously they weren't being
serious but you know it's just but there
are idiots that would take that serious
like we gotta stand up against this
hurricane this foreign invader well
wasn't the hurricane at Cannon
category-five coming in to the coast
right it was still supposed to be some
and all of a sudden it turned into a
three yeah I think bullets work no yeah
because they were also saying that you
know they didn't expect anyone to
actually take it serious and that what
they've learned out of this whole
experience is that a good chunk of
people in this world don't understand
sarcasm this is true I mean yeah and so
typical you guys will be sarcastic and
then a lot of people actually take you
guys seriously we're like 90% there
should I say sarcastic but kind of sucks
listen all you [ __ ] would have been
inside there an era and I'd have been
outside with my rifle okay and you know
what else I would do I would take a
little bit further because I like to
talk [ __ ] I would have peed on the
hurricane a case of beer I drink the
whole thing and I'd just be peeing on
average you ever peed outside in a wit
on a windy day it man I peed all over
myself
Oh windy as hell and I wasn't pee I was
with the wind behind me it started
coming downhill toward me so it was like
hitting this block of wind and coming
right back at like yet just easily
turned a little bit and the point I'm
going I'm trying to I'm tonight stepping
and maybe I shouldn't I should have
turned but we're sitting behind these I
didn't want to turn around why are you
pissing people behind you know they're
behind me so I just I was up I was
peeing toward the mouth you don't want
to show his dick to pee yeah there you
could've walked away too
I couldn't I was I gotta go see once you
started peeing on yourself we just kept
in her stuff
no I excited going left to right we had
a 180 like 180 Roy
you don't know these things about like
people like when you can't really stop
it very well now you can't breath once
it goes it's just you could hold it for
like another three seconds and after
that you feel like you Dickson's have
you have you stopped mid P I've tried
like that's what they do in North Korea
to torture be surprised that was a
torture tactic there's no worse than she
[ __ ] hurts oh yeah no I watched my
brother peed on pee on his own forehead
once because we were weird we were
pulled off the side of the road during a
road trip and he had to go so bad and he
we just see the back of him right Oh
he'd never live that down we talked
about that [ __ ] for [ __ ] years
Oh because dicks are weird I think he
was taking his dick out and he had to go
so bad he just whipped it out he's like
going as he was whipping it out and just
oh my god you know either one of the
streets head no what's great though is
you know he's watching him doing good
for our last story the city of Los
Angeles is trying to tackle climate
change by painting its streets with the
paint that can reduce the effects of
rising temperatures explain this we've
been meeting this that's not real we've
been needing this witchcraft no so this
gray paint it's called cool seal and
it's a light-colored paint and so what
they're saying is that they've already
tested in multiple parts of the city
like in North Hollywood San Fernando
Valley that's what it's hot as yeah
here's the paint and what they're saying
is that they've already seen a 10-degree
difference and these streets actually
have the paint so that it is working
that's what it looks like makes it
brighter
oh yeah it's cooling the streets down
and so what they're saying is that with
these streets that are cooler the people
use less AC and so internally
it's not gonna happen I mean from 100
110 to 100 degrees still you see it's
still hot yeah big difference
hey dude if it's only 100 I won't use my
CC I think we need more of some scented
paint I want to go to downtown Skid Row
imagine you're walking down the street
and it smells like [ __ ] bum piss but
the walls in the building smell like
[ __ ] strawberries yeah but I don't
want a strawberry there's a lot of
restaurants in LA so like I get a whiff
of Indian food and some [ __ ] yeah like
I'm just walking around or is it the
[ __ ] it's constantly human piss and
[ __ ] yeah everywhere I walk I don't LA
so unique man like I've seen people [ __ ]
in front of me so many times that it's
like disturbing that nobody should see
that nobody just see that light at least
40 times that's how I though because
like you could be walking in like it's
like oh is that dog sugar human [ __ ]
cause it could be could be both that's
how I like South Pasadena is nice but
I've seen that like three or four times
like at night like this dude [ __ ]
squatted
they looked at us like we were doing
something wrong from LA ya know I
complain but I'm probably gonna complain
about everywhere I live no man there's
always pros and cons but just the bum
situation though I just check with
something else they do - do you live
somewhere in LA where it gets really hot
there's no hope though you could you
could cover you have to cover it in a
plastic bubble and pump it with air
because in the valley it's insane yeah
like it's so it's like the [ __ ]
surface of a different planet no it is
nothing the people actually
no but I think this is great a great way
of using City money for something and
pretending like it's affecting things
like that's what we always do it's it's
so funny I guess that at least like
paving the roadways right oh I mean our
asphalt does couldn't contribute to like
the hot hot summers that we get yeah
because I you know Ellie hey have you
ever flown into Ellie and seen like what
a suburb jungle it is it's just nothing
no dirt it's just all oh yeah that's
right so it comes down and that black
asphalt just takes up all the heat I
just love that every 30 years the the
the saga changes right like 30 years ago
it was global cooling now then it became
global warming about 10 years ago and
now it's just climate change and
gentlemen this is this change how it
works but we're gonna figure it out
like I just love all that [ __ ] so what
every time I get it's like we're doing
this to combat I'm like yeah okay well
when we hear the next study I can't wait
to do what the change is it's like it's
like red wine is good for you and then
you hear red wine is bad for you or like
vitamin C is preventive for sickness oh
now we find out it's not we don't know
[ __ ] sorry but the only place where the
science is settled is global warming
climate change global cooling I love
that it's the only place everywhere else
we just found out the cradle of
civilization mom is not Africa
we found out it's in Europe but there's
like [ __ ] 3,000 documentaries like
welcome to the cradle of civilization
the plains of Africa I mean and they
just found out that this is not the case
so it's like you don't know anything
yeah like I love but they're gonna find
something else I think they recently
found a structure in Turkey or something
like that that predates what I mean
megastructures or something like like
when we were supposed to be
hunter-gatherers and all that stuff it
was like 10,000 BC or some deep yeah it
predates I was a scientist and every
time that happens it's like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] dumb ass yeah we're gonna keep
finding crazier things we always do I
mean look look there's you know you've
heard of the medieval warming period
where it was hot
than it is now uh yeah in a medieval Ice
Age exactly there was one little icy to
whatever's I have like a little ice age
every 10,000 years or something like
that yeah that's when um they're saying
you know those violins what is it called
the stratosphere or Stratus yeah
Stradivarius the reason why those those
those violins are so like expensive and
good is because very much time there was
a little ice age so the all the wood and
all the trees like you can't we're not
gonna get that back so the trees from
that era it's like they make the best
violins but that's how they find out
it's like oh yeah there was a little Ice
Age during that time in Europe the state
of California is trying to use 100%
renewable energy by 2045 2045 that's
[ __ ] a hella long from now god damn
100% that's pretty faint according to
I've seen it happen yeah and according
to a lot of the current studies like ten
of the current studies like we're all
[ __ ] by 2050 - or some [ __ ] so what's
the point
no no but kids know if they actually
cared about preventing it they would do
nuclear power wall the [ __ ] wall
that's all they would do because the
only thing that can actually reverse
these so-called effects that we're
talking about is nuclear power and yet
all the same people who always tell us
oh we got a you know turn off your air
conditioners and all this [ __ ] they
never want to build new nuclear power
plants that's the only thing that would
actually solve the problem you have well
because we use a lot of coal right like
America China everyone mm-hmm and
nuclear power does not have those high
amounts of high high amount of output
for a low less co2 in the atmosphere
there's you know they don't release co2
in the atmosphere and nuclear powers but
but that's what I'm saying like if you
actually wanted to solve the problem
they would be doing this if it was that
dire they would be doing all this
nuclear energy every what they're not
it's a it's such a [ __ ] joke that way
well the world has a nuclear power
phobia though you know it does it's um
it's I think it's a media thing I need
every brand nuclear power yeah with the
tsunami and in the radiation going into
our
and all that stir but maybe just don't
build it next to an ocean well they do
it they do it so that they can stick and
they can sink them in there if [ __ ] goes
down okay yeah but then so what
Chernobyl doesn't happen oh we got those
mutating animals or [ __ ] all of them
lives but that's pretty good you can get
Fukushima and Chernobyl other than that
like we vet we have thousands of plants
all over the world damn dude
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]